when you think of cutting edge
technology at sea you might be thinking
of stuff like this
but there's an incoming revolution on
the high seas that isn't quite as sexy
but could be significantly more
impactful
container shipping is the key component
of global trade about 80 or 90 percent
of all the world's goods are transported
at sea at some point
and these ships carry trillions of
dollars of goods on them and without
them there would be no globalization
but there's a significant unseen cost to
the modern era of global commerce about
three percent of all the world's co2
missions come from shipping
three percent may not sound like a lot
but that's roughly comparable to the
entire co2 output of germany
or in other words around the same amount
of emissions from all forms of aviation
combined
since reducing trade isn't a likely
option what about a technological
improvement to help reduce the emissions
from these well-stocked maritime
behemoths
[Music]
transport by c has always been the most
cost efficient method of moving i mean
it was like that in the stone age and
it's still like that today
in the more recent history it was in the
1970s that the big breakthrough came
when the use of standard size containers
became the norm
that's really what revolutionized trade
and made globalization as we know today
possible
today we are used to buying things in
europe and the us that's made in china
50 years ago that was not the norm
that's the container that made that
possible
only about six or seven thousand
container ships handle this big conveyor
belt of goods
they have doubled in size many times
over during the last couple of decades
and now the biggest container ships
there are can carry more than 20 000
containers and
longer than 400 meters
[Music]
so why not electrify a fleet of cargo
ships and take advantage of the
emissions cuts that come with it
well some are trying
take yara a fertilizer company in norway
and their electric autonomous ship the
brook land
and we can start by addressing the
question why is a fertilizer company
building ships at all
we have a lot of focus of making
sustainable products producing food for
the whole population in a sustainable
way is one of the important tasks that
we as a company see
and transportation and the supply chain
is also part of the environmental load
that we put on the society
the bitcoin it's unique because it is
electric and then also emission free and
it's going to be autonomous without any
ship crew on board
we are exporting about
20 000 containers
a year
so that will then eliminate 40 thousand
truck drives through the town of
portland
the brook land isn't going to be any
cheaper to operate than a traditional
vessel at least for now but according to
yara that's not its purpose it is mod
effect on the environment
reducing co2 emission and also an
important factor that this ship has got
a lot of attention and it's been a kind
of a catalyst for the others also to
develop green mode team transport
but the arabic land has a significant
limitation
range
a similarly sized vessel with a diesel
engine can travel up to 5 000 nautical
miles the arab land around 80.
they will use it for a very specific
route in in norway between two sites
fairly close to each other
the ship can carry about
120 containers and you would need about
200 of these small ships to match one of
the very large container vessels that's
out there
so the yarrow brook land has a solid but
niche potential application
for longer range ships the technology
faces the same issues that were common
to early road going evs
if you look at a tesla
tesla has a battery that weighs 1200
pounds
if you should fit a battery into a
container ship that's 400 meters long
it would just be massive
because of these limitations the
industry's heavy hitters are turning
elsewhere for carbon cutting
mirsk the world's largest shipping
company by vessels owned currently
consumes around 12 million tons of oil
per year
which is about what the entire world
produces every day
in order to reach its goal of being
carbon neutral by 2040 the company is
looking to change up what's in the tank
the power requirements are just too high
for battery technology at the moment
you're talking about
ships with an engine on with a more than
100 000 horsepower
in the marine industry the only real way
to reduce emissions is to actually
change the fuel
to begin that change mursk turned to man
solutions i managed solutions as part of
the volkswagen group i'm the oldest
industrial company in germany founded in
1758 we're a little bit different to the
car industry because we operate in the
marine industry
with ap muller mursk we'll receive an
order for 12 methanol fuel ships so the
idea is to have a carbon neutral ship
completely carbon neutral
methanol is quite an interesting fuel
because of course it's very co2 neutral
[Music]
the second thing is it's liquefies
ambient temperature so actually it's
relatively simple to store and use
the genius thing about the engines that
we produce is because of our modular
design we can actually modify the
engines fairly simply to run on
different fuels and actually a lot of
our engines are supplied in the dual
fuel mode so they can run on one fuel
today in a different fuel tomorrow
there's many types of new fuels that
will allow us to decarbonize the
industry but of course what we need is a
kind of transition and you can go to
liquid natural gas or even synthetic
natural gas which give us good
reductions in co2
we intend to have a vessel operating in
2024 and ammonia which of course is the
absolute game changer in terms of
emissions
[Music]
some of these alternative fuels however
have drawbacks
they're looking at ammonia which is a
highly toxic chemical but it's also co2
neutral
obviously the disadvantage is that it's
very dangerous both for humans and
marine life
liquefied natural gas some shipping
lines are looking at that the problem
with that is obviously that it's not co2
neutral it just reduces the co2
emissions from the ships
[Music]
but another solution is methanol which
is sourced from green electricity
methanol is readily available today and
really is carbon neutral of all the
technologies i think methanol is for
sure the the short or medium term future
there's an infrastructure around
methanol i think methanol at the moment
seems to be more available and of course
the technology is proven
although switching to alternative fuels
is expected to add 10 to 12 percent to
shipping costs this could be the perfect
time for shipping companies to add in a
buffer for that premium
in the last two years the industry has
been in great shape the reason why
they're in great shape as well many are
aware that the world suffers from supply
chain issues but it's actually an
advantage for the companies that owns
the ships because they can charge higher
prices at the moment so there's a lot of
cash flow in the container shipping
industry right now and that should
enable the companies and ship owners to
invest in new technologies that reduce
global emissions
while these mammoth vessels make
incremental progress in decarbonizing
smaller ships are more readily adopting
new technologies
[Music]
take primary's mayflower vessel
using hybrid solar wind and diesel
propulsion it's equipped to travel
autonomously with no crew to conduct
research on marine health
it's designed to cruise around the
oceans and collect scientific data so
climate data water quality data data
about marine mammals and bring back
samples and also transmit samples off
the boat into the
into the ether for consumption by the
scientific community
according to primary the advantages of
the mayflower being unmanned and ai
driven will be both in its increased
efficiency and its ability to go where
most ships never do
one of the things to bear in mind with
these vessels is once you remove all the
people stuff
they become extremely efficient in the
sense that the power it takes to move
this vessel over long distances is
absurdly low by comparison to a vessel
the same size carrying people on it
it's very very green because it just
sips on the fuel but it's an electric
dual electric motors that are driven by
lithium iron phosphate battery system
similar to what you find in the tesla
and then there are solar panels that
charge emergency batteries and then also
charge the main batteries so that if we
lose main propulsion for some reason the
solar power and battery systems that are
adjacent to the primary batteries will
keep the navigation lights and
communications and position data live
then the main batteries that drive the
engines and run all the sophisticated
systems are periodically charged by a
biodiesel generator so we can use bio
fuel or we can use straight diesel
whichever we prefer
[Music]
it doesn't replace ships with people on
it but it sort of democratized the
ability to collect data and produce
information that we can all share
so that when we do send a very expensive
ship with people on it out for very long
voyages into the middle of nowhere that
those people are best spending their
time on the areas that will produce the
most results in terms of answering the
big questions that boats like this help
to ask
the dream would be to have many many
many ships like this so if you look at
where we get our data about the ocean
it's almost completely biased to the
commercial shipping channels right there
ships going back and forth on major
trading rounds
ships like mayflower and many others
like it both very small ones even larger
ones are what we need to kind of reduce
the cost of collecting that fundamental
data and producing that sort of first
tier of information
primary plans to send the mayflower on
its first transatlantic voyage in april
across the pond in alameda california
another company is looking to commit
swarms of electric autonomous drones to
the seas
that company is cell drone
the first vehicles were designed to be
data gathering robots that really gather
atmospheric and oceanographic data which
is kind of the critical piece of the
puzzle we need to understand climate
change and the rate of change
so we started gathering data on fish
stocks on the water column itself
that led us to ocean mapping so mapping
the seabed
what we excel at with the robot is kind
of the long monotonous or dangerous
things that people shouldn't be doing so
persistent present operations in the
high arctic um southern ocean which is
too rough to go with the human
hurricane explosion's a great example
the boats are electric vehicles so they
run on battery power
it is winning power propulsion and solar
powered for the electricity for the
computers and so on
electrification of you know marine
systems is key but i'll go further than
that saying it's not just
electrification it's harnessing
renewable sources of so wind and solar
to power those vehicles along real
challenge for any maritime vessel is
having enough power on board to propel
you so if you don't harvest power along
the way you have to carry that as stored
power either a huge amount of batteries
or an alternative fuel source diesel
hydrogen or other so for us we try and
maximize the utility of renewable
sources and obviously that's wind
setting ships kind of one of the oldest
technologies on the planet and a true
reliable and sustainable form of power
so we utilize that a lot and that
reduces the amount of fuel you have to
take and reduce the amount of mechanical
load on the vehicles less time you can
run engineer for the longer that's going
to last
but there are areas of the world where
you don't have a lot of sunlight
northern hemisphere in the winter up in
the arctic obviously a lot of it's
frozen but in the unfrozen area where we
operate um very very low light levels
very short days very short summers and
that means we struggle for power in the
winter months
right now we're using high efficiency
small diesel engines that run at kind of
a very efficient rpm uh to charge
batteries in a very short period of time
so like a diesel electric system on a
ship we use engines to charge batteries
and then you run the ship of batteries
having backup combustion engines proves
just how hard it will be for ocean-going
vessels to completely ditch carbon
emitting fuels
regardless stakeholders in the industry
seem to agree that progress must
continue and fast
if we can decarbonize this industry and
we need to act very very quickly because
it's not just about the new ships it's
about the existing ships then we can
have a dramatic impact to make sure we
hit the targets that been set out
we needed to act yesterday not tomorrow
we needed to act yesterday so the
quicker we can get this moving and the
better for everybody
[Music]
you